uh because whenever i do puzzles what i
try to do is i try to take them from my
own games
because you get this interesting
perspective having lived through it like
okay you know what were the ideas that
that i thought were important and how
much of it did i get right how much did
i get wrong and i think that's kind of
the exercise that you need to do let's
say when you're working through a puzzle
book
you know the goal is never to get
well i mean if you get it right that
feels good but it shouldn't be your
primary objective right to solve the
puzzle that's not why you're practicing
tactics
you're practicing to sort of break down
your thinking process and see what
you're doing right what you're doing
wrong so that when you have a game
you sort of
recognize okay usually i mess up
when when
certain things start to happen and
you're alert and aware of it so let's
see
here we go
no
yes
all right so
let's start with an easy one
this is actually taken from a game
played
uh this morning
at the berlin grand prix i don't know
have you guys been following this
tournament you have yeah um what do you
think so far
no comment
okay
um
yeah there are a lot of exciting games
um you know how the format works
yeah they have they have four groups
of four players each
the winner of each group advances to a
knockout stage
right so
um
you're gonna end up with four players
sort of doing like a semi-final and a
final
and uh the two players to reach the fin
um sorry the two players that finish
um
at the top of the standings
in the grand prix qualify for the
candidates right oh yeah and the winner
of the candidates plays magnus so
um this is the final leg of the grand
prix so after this tournament is over
the the final
candidate spots will will have been
awarded so we'll have a complete picture
of what the candidate's tournament is
going to be like this
exactly now they actually kicked
karjakin out of the candidates so a spot
opened up there so that makes things
kind of they should uh what's that
yeah i mean uh there's there's a lot of
debate
and uh speculation as to who's going to
get that spot what the criteria is going
to be
so it's not guaranteed that it's going
to be dingler
yeah i mean he's he's fun to watch so
and he deserves it you know he's been up
there
yeah no absolutely that that would be a
pretty solid
choice playing in brazil
weren't
uh
i was playing in brazil but not against
ding loren i don't know i know that i'm
just like i just recognized your face
were you in brazil i wasn't in brazil
but um
a series of tournaments in south america
i played two in argentina one in brazil
one in uruguay so i had a little uh
tournament schedule
tour planned
and now
like one of the rockstars
it was in uruguay
yeah no i was i was there uh so you know
you never know when i'm gonna appear
uh
or where
but anyway um
i do have some games from that brazil
tournament that i was gonna use for for
today's class is everything all right
oh um
what would you like me to do well
because it's cut off the board's coming
up you want me to just move it like this
no don't do that you got a full screen
yeah oh you want me to full screen yeah
no you want to do it yeah okay should i
get up
um
oh
all right there we go
all right so i'm just gonna
i also don't like to just show you a
position i kind of like to see how the
players got there but we're not going to
spend a lot of time on that
um
yeah so i mean
essepenko is no slouch right i mean he's
like
he's the player of the moment really
he's like the the russian hope
uh very young player very talented
who sso
yeah i know i mean but levon is is kind
of
an established player right he's he's
been around for a long time you know uh
he's not he's playing well now
but
there was a moment where he was like 28
20 or something like some ridiculous
rating he was like number two in the
world
everybody thought he was going to be the
next guy playing magnus
and then you know he kind of just
got into a
a slump there that he seems to be
getting out of
so
he's an incredibly creative attacking
player
so anyway
we're gonna we're gonna breeze through
the opening
because
i want to get to this moment because to
me the game starts at this point
you played this today i really played
this exact game
wow that's crazy
yeah and um
you didn't know that aronian had played
the same game oh that's funny
okay what book is that
um
you have it out there it's a
it's a queen scandal like a repertoire
but it's
i'll show you that do you know who the
author is
that's all right you can get it later
don't worry about it
okay
all right so anyway um
the interesting thing is apparently
his opponent played bishop takes c3 here
and now i'm guessing after bishop takes
c3 the idea must be to go knight e4
but i don't know i mean here it seems
like i can just go rook c1
castles
uh maybe safeguard my bishop
i think white should probably be a
little bit better
in the game black played bishop f8
and this is where the theme
gets introduced right
when you look at this position what do
you think like what what would you play
as white what would you
try to sink your teeth into in black's
position
what do you see as
as a liability for black
possibly
the um open c file
or
i mean our semi-open file right i mean
you would think oh maybe i can go like
rook c1 and put pressure on this pawn
the thing about it though is that this
pawn is fairly easy to defend for black
black's idea is to go c5 knight bd7 and
that pawn on c5 is going to have
protection from the pawn the knight the
bishop the rook if i need it right so
black's pieces are really going to swarm
towards that c pawn so so black has his
bases covered so who was it
brooke
okay so this is a repertoire for white
yes
that must be his d4 series
okay yeah um that's interesting i didn't
know he he recommended this i'll have to
check that out
but anyway
the c pawn might be the first thing that
stands out
and uh not surprisingly it's the first
thing that black has sort of taken care
to make sure that
it's not going to be a huge problem so
we're just trying to figure out
what about black's position sort of
stands out to you as a potential target
like how would you
how would you create problems for black
yeah
maybe
right that's what he was saying right
sort of targeting the c7 pawn but
actually it's very easy to defend
oh i wasn't there i was just controlled
because something interesting has
happened here right black castled very
quickly and white didn't castle at all
so
you would think
yeah you would think that
this would be
a liability for white
not for black right to leave the king in
the center
but in this position
okay but i mean let's say okay you go
you go h4 i go c5
so what do you do
i mean what was the idea of h4 what was
how are you gonna mate me maybe
like i'm just waiting for my phone to do
something with age four maybe you start
a little bit of attack yeah so you have
to be careful not to
oh is it night isn't that she's
okay so now now we're talking about
something pretty real right ng5 yeah
knight g5 this is this is the key move
uh after knight g5 black is under
pressure black has to deal with the
threat on this pawn on h7 right
the mistake with h4 it's not that h4 is
a bad move
but h4
is a piece of the puzzle it's not the
puzzle right so what you have to do
before you
because i can tell you're getting
excited about this attack you you see a
move boom boom boom you want to play it
right away and that's that's what you
need to fight when you're attacking you
need to sort of take a deep breath and
say okay
how does this fit in
with
not just
one threat or one move but how can i get
all of my pieces to participate in sort
of uh the same target right so yeah what
were you gonna say so what is the black
dude because if black plays
h6 can't you then go h4
well you could go h4 but you have a much
better move here so this is going to be
our first sort of warm-up
tactical oh i mean you can wear your
bishop
so so let's try to be specific right
because when it comes to tactics
you want to avoid using words and
instead you want to try to use
variations as much as possible right so
so
tell me your sequence
i would probably place
h4
also i mean what happens if i do take it
after h4
then i take back and it's very bad
because
sh moves i want moves right so okay so
it's knight
h4 h takes g5 h65 and then h takes uh
hg5 yeah and then his knights are tied
so he moves the knight where does it go
oh it goes to e4 and it's not nothing
right so you have to be careful that's
why you want to avoid situations where
you're like oh h4 and attack right
that's no good that's not going to get
you anywhere you have to
follow through with the variation at
least until a logical conclusion right
where you say okay
all of the captures and all of the
checks have been dealt with and i don't
see anything yeah
um
and if knight takes
right and if king h8 instead of knight
takes
yeah so here you have made in two right
you're not blind i saw it
no you didn't see it what you did was
you the first thing that you saw was h4
so you've been trying to make h4 work
all the time right and that's a mistake
because what that does it gives you this
tunnel vision
what your mind is doing is saying h4 h4
h4 h4 h4 and it's closing you off from
alternatives
so if you start viewing
moves as part of a greater scheme
then you're more open to okay what other
player can i incorporate into this
attacking team because you're not just
going to give checkmate with h4 it's not
enough
so
the point of knight g5
is to force g6 right which is basically
the only move
and now h4 makes a lot more sense
because you have this hook on g6 so that
you can play
h5 h takes g6 and then your rook joins
the attack as well notice how
gradually
the attacking
team
is incorporating more and more players
now it's not just a queen it's not just
the bishop it's not just the knight it's
not just the pawn it's not it's not just
the rook like all of these pieces
together
are creating
uh
are increasing the pressure so
black plays c5
white goes h5 and now that there's no
bishop h7 black figure is okay now it's
the time to go h6
so this is our
our second hurdle
how should white play here
so
any ideas
in the chat they're saying that here
that the tunnel vision move is h takes
g6 i don't know i wouldn't say
oh yeah
i was gonna say i don't think that's
correct because if you take h6 they're
not they can
and uh well let's say they
take them you kind of you kind
where does it run because if you bring
your oh you can't even bring her up like
if you check your check
so this is actually what happened in the
game
and uh to me it didn't seem obvious
how the attack would develop from here
right so you wouldn't
i don't exchange
right but we didn't go into this to win
an exchange besides we already gave up a
night right so what we would be doing we
would be getting some material back yeah
so
so really the material issue is is
secondary unless we win a lot of
material like enough to put the game
away which is definitely not the case
here
so the question is how
can we
maintain the pressure on this king how
can we keep the game alive right in
terms of our attack what if you go check
on g6 yeah bring your coin instead of
taking it okay so for example if i go
here
or maybe maybe i should go here i don't
once you know there and then don't you
just go to rook h7 knight takes your
stakes and it's
like your queen comes in next month okay
so notice you're doing the same thing as
before right you're saying like when
remember when
knight g5
we looked at h6 and you were like okay
h4 and just attack and all of a sudden
you stop there but if you went if you
would have gone one or two more moves
you saw h takes h694 and all of a sudden
you have nothing right so
what happens after
rook h7 knight takes bishop takes yes
you're threatening maiden 2 with queen
g6 yes
yeah right any move that stops queen g6
and your attack is over
so how can white
remain
latched to the the threat of the game
which is
the attack on the king right and for the
attack on the king to be successful
we need
an attacking team we need pieces to work
together
right so so it's clear that this this is
basically our attacking team yes the
only pieces we have left we don't have
much of a choice i'm sorry did you have
your hand up or is yeah oh i'm sorry i
thought you were just like supporting oh
i was just waiting for you i'm sorry
yeah yeah
um
i think
like putting the bishop on h7
has potential okay so this looks
interesting now right because all of a
sudden you don't have these moves to
stop queen g6 so now queen g6 is coming
that looks pretty interesting
um
it actually looks pretty devastating
right so same idea except you get to
keep your rook seems like a pretty swell
deal
and if i take
well again against either move i'm just
gonna go king f6 right so
so do you take with the rook or the
queen
um
mm-hmm
bishop uh
g7 oh but then you literally bring it on
h6
king f7
do you take the bishop
okay so queen h8 bishop g7 rook h6 king
f7
so
just uh just call out the sequence that
you're looking at
oh yeah queen and shade uh bishop g7
rookie six
king f7
yeah
and then you
take with the queen take what
uh
the mission queen takes queen takes
that's me
question wait what
bishop g7 so here
here
here here and now you take oh yeah
and then king takes right that doesn't
work
it's close
not that close
i think you have a much simpler way of
going about things
i mean
yeah right you just take the
take the bishop
you still have the attack but now you're
up a pawn instead of being down a piece
and your knights coming into the attack
so it's really not so much about oh i
want a bishop
you've got more pieces coming into the
attack with knight takes d5 so this is
completely over
that's why black played king e7
yeah
what was that i said i said i saw that
earlier
it's a pretty big deal uh
so after king e7
what do we do now because now obviously
bishop h7 doesn't make any sense
we could try
queen f5
and what's your idea after queen f5
like if we got to move again rick brooke
or uh yeah h7
and after knight takes
and
king c6
you're so close
we can
take we're going to take rookie anywhere
is there something
well but now i'll probably just go queen
takes right
oh no but you still have the bishop on
g6 no no you're taking on e8 with the
bishop so i can go queen takes because
you already gave me your rook
i i don't know let's say i'll make like
a random move right just to see if it
works you're saying check here
check here here here oh you're saying
take with the queen
for being down material it looks like
i'm up a piece
well i see one two three four
and you only have three of those
yes
but maybe what could be interesting is
starting with this move taking away d6
and now threatening here but i don't
know maybe maybe queen d7
it feels strange
yeah right the idea is to clear uh an
escape square but i don't know because
maybe i'll have check
and take here notice that
i'm always like one move away from just
getting my piece back
maintaining a position with an extra
pawn
and a tremendous attack right now here
this is hanging so
so this is a
an easy flowing attack for white because
you can
even if you don't checkmate you'll get
whatever you invest it back with
interest
so i do think that
you know after queen f5 you have knight
b5 ideas rook h7 idiot queen e5 ideas
queen takes g5 ideas
there are too many fronts for black to
cover here so
black played bishop g7 and now what do
we do
by the way queen f5 is a tough move
right because
it's a move that threatens to threaten
something right but
the important thing is to identify that
you know
that you need to checkmate this king and
you know that the pieces that are going
to do it are going to be your queen
bishop and rook
and if you don't see
a direct win right away what you need to
do is you need to start getting closer
to the king
so queen f5 is an important move because
now the queen is creeping up the board
and getting closer to that king and
creating new targets right not just the
king if if all black had to worry about
was not getting mated
that would be a lot easier for black but
now also black has to worry about not
losing the knight you know not losing
the rook so
after bishop g7
how does white continue this attack
and this is really where
where you see how what a brilliant
attacker
aronian is
it's almost like he's enjoying this
attack like he doesn't want it to end
um so you're saying queen e5 yeah and
after king d7
bishop f5
and then
well maybe against queen e5 i can go
king f8 maybe that's better
because the bishop f5 does look pretty
scary there i have to go king c6
if i go king f8
right so you're saying here here
here and here where does the knight come
in
oh i didn't see it
where
i don't think i have any other
moves now i mean maybe maybe this is
worth looking at but first i would
i would ask myself well what's wrong if
i just go here
looks like a much safer square for the
king
right this rook is attacking your queen
but if you take it now you're starting
to lose attackers this might still be
kind of interesting because you take
here but black takes here this looks
messy right and it looks like
our attacking team is is being sort of
decimated and
we're not getting
to do enough damage to black's position
so i think we can do much much better
than queen e5 and taking the rook
can we
i'm wondering
brilliant
so e4 is just an outright brilliant move
because
whenever you're attacking and you can't
seem to breach the defenses you need to
bring more pieces in right you need to
expand your team and once this bishop
gets to g5 the game's just going to be
over
so
it must be pretty scary for black to
have a king right in front of it though
right
um
but but i'm noticing
you're
you're basing a lot of decisions on what
things look like or the first
impressions that they make
and
if chess if you could figure out all of
chess by first impressions it would be
such an easier game than it is right but
a lot of the times
things are the opposite of what they
look like so yes you would think oh i
left my king in the center and there's a
rook on the e file why would i ever go
e4
but there's there's no reason not to do
it right there's no
sequence that you can point to
killing me man
yeah man
i'm hearing the limelight
um
so anyway the thing that matters is
you have to make this king right your
your game for whatever goes down but you
need to get more pieces closer to that
king or you're not going to be able to
checkmate it
so
um black
just like white tries to bring more
attackers black's trying to bring more
defenders
so after uh
knight c6
what do we do
all right if bishop takes
i think black's idea is to go knight
takes
bishop takes knight no this is a good
point so bishop takes
okay and here
okay thank you
looks kind of annoying because this king
gets tucked away quite nicely on f8
whenever things get get really
do you heated it on
okay so here's another interesting
suggestion
and um
can i can i play this move again
yes
you had a good point now i'm actually
winning your queen
so so black is preparing an interesting
counter attack here with knight takes d4
so we really we really want to play this
move but we don't want to give black
this counter play
that is not true
so knight takes
knight takes
down
ah now bishop takes right so i gave you
a knight but i got to stop you from
doing what you wanted right
um yes
so at first it might seem hard to think
of that right to think
why
would i sacrifice a knight just to stop
knight takes d4 but once you realize
what this game is about what both sides
are are playing this tug of war over
then it makes perfect sense because your
bishop gets into the attack and you've
stopped knight d4
so
um let's see
what happened here
oh that's right um white took on e8
first which i don't know if it was the
most accurate move
and after queen takes then he went
knight takes d5 and after knight takes
bishop takes
and king d6 so what's the idea if black
gets greedy and says okay let me just
keep my extra piece
right and it's almost the same the same
idea right after takes takes i have king
f8 yeah
although yeah
i'll still take my king's chances over
yours right uh
it's
not that bad
yeah um
very nice nice so you
here you didn't get the checkmate but
you just took down so much material
yeah you just went too much that's just
that's game over it is game over
so so black played king d6
and now after queen takes king c7
huh i was looking at this line first
it's a good line
and now how does this
continue
black resigned all right
black's not even up material here black
is down material
white has a rook
and three pawns for two minor pieces
which
generally speaking is enough for a
decisive advantage but on top of that
your your king is getting destroyed here
right
no and you're gonna lose you're gonna
lose this bishop i got bishop f4 ideas
so yeah this is just a hopeless position
okay
so that was that was our warm-up
warm-up yeah that was easy i asked
earlier what was this opening i want to
say it looks like a catalan
uh well no because a catalan would
involve playing g3 bishop g2 right first
so that was pretty easy to rule out
no but this was a this was an im
nimzo indian rogozin they can usually
transpose
uh
went like that and now queen c2
and uh i don't know i'm going to have to
check that avroc book to see what he
recommends here
because your move probably bishop takes
c3 is the best in knight e4 yeah